this experience and I know cuz you've
hung with all of you guys have hung with
us this experience was to be able to
show that each of us individually are
funny and write good jokes can deliver
them in the moment but that we can
deliver in the moment because we want to
see we want to be seen as two
individuals that are great and then you
come together and you form
Voltron you know what I'm saying like
that that's the plan and that's we
always love to show because for us we
don't want to be the gimmick that we
just get things because we're twins we
they just get put there they're funny
they're twins who are you know we want
to be funny and oh the fact they're
twins is fascinating and interesting and
it makes a battle between two people the
most interesting battle you see yeah and
about that battle part man where's that
I don't dislike each other at all I
can't be there is anger always between
us like if you ever seen us on a set
doing like rehearsing for something or
that we're both in if one person fuck's
up a little bit the other person just
reigns down so much it's mainly Jason
yeah it's yeah we're on each other
because we cuz you know in a weird way
it's like he's a bizarre sort of
extension of me or at least I feel
comfortable enough to criticize him the
way I would criticize myself and so
there's a little bit of that in it but
it's so bad that we were doing our show
like yeah cheap seats there'd be like
crew members can't longtime camera guys
where we'd start yelling AJ like I gotta
take a break at Ali I can't watch it's
like we did get like that sometimes not
all the time but we're humans were
people like to the prompter on it back
do maybe you need to make the letters
bigger cuz he can't see it you know I
forgot how to read he doesn't know how
to read anymore it's just that kind of
like passive-aggressive stuff oh but I
will say this about the battles because
you know we were on the show with Joe
list and his wife and they were so funny
and we were talking to Joe Osmond and
wife by the husband wife and we were
talking ahead of time and he was like I
think people are gonna see my jokes and
think I'm just being mean to this woman
and I do think right
now the the in the you know in the
shadow of you know footage of Ray Rice
knocking out his wife and people you
know there it is like a time where that
taboo is a giant hurdle to leap over
when Randy and I step on the stage it's
like all things are events all things
have been evened out the playing field
is literally leveled so no one feels
like a bully over the other person it's
Rock'em Sock'em robots you don't know
whose jaws gonna pop a sibling
same-gender ever instead of exactly and
so it allows abuse or disputes right so
it allows everybody to just sort of cast
all that stuff off and just enjoy the
battle we try to vary it what I mean
what I loved about the battle was you
talk about how your regular act is
building each other up and that's what
you did in the battle while tearing each
other down like the exchange about the
hemorrhoids earlier like the chemistry
even when you guys went in on Jeselnik
or jeff together Anthony nice beer I was
referring to Nikki all right Jeff you
look like the two of us if we were
conjoined
[Laughter]
Wow you look like you absorbed your twin
yesterday he's coming at us with fight
he's gonna come out with something in
his joke I've seen you guys I know it
was just nice to see you guys I told Dan
Van Kirk who does the podcast dumb
people to hell with us and he was like
quote and Dan thank you and Dan was like
so Dan who's ever the positive person is
like so he had to admit you guys got
laughs we just were so ready to be like
we wanted to do what's called when when
each of us start to pile on our friend
Scott Rogowski who hosts HQ another plug
sorry but our friend Scott Rogowski
calls how many name drops gonna have
this you're causing Sklar Vilanch is
like okay jazz neck but but but you talk
about and we talk about this with you
with Moses we're I mean we're studiers
of this of the roast battle we love the
roast battle nobody promotes it more
than we do honor yes and in general in
the world because we do feel like we
came to it as fans and then got to be a
part of it but I do think that the best
Roasters are the people who take the
roasting format and they're doing it but
then they make it their own and put it
in their own voice so it sounds like
them it's unlike anything that's come
before it but it's still roasting right
you guys put it in two voices yes those
in an energy between the two of us Pat
we're we're like okay there's got to be
energy between the two of us the way we
normally fight when we fight in our
lives it that has to translate there has
to be real anger between the two of us
there has to be dialogue in between the
jokes yeah that's funny yeah it's funny
asides right yeah and even if you're not
saying a joke
even if Jay was like on stage one of my
pheromones he's like can I get to my jug
oh that was like like yeah I'm like what
are you doing get to it can I do my
jokes do it okay
[Laughter]
order order I mean my favorite moment
was the you brought that energy that
we're used to at the roast battle into
it when you demanded your own overtime
when Moses tried to get on stage and you
were like no we got more I was feeling
the energy yeah loving it we wouldn't
have talked about this but ahead of time
but I was like we were feeling the
energy I was like we have more jokes
we're gonna get them out we're gonna get
them out yeah wave them off for real
moments you know it's like we're
comedians like anytime there's a mess-up
or when you're recording a comedy album
or something like that
no I'll a special our last special we
shot in in Chicago and you should we
shot two shows the first show these
plugs going when you record shows you
guys know this so the first show we
recorded and it was loose and it was fun
and we were like we got 70% of it 80% of
it okay let's go in the next show and
like really nail it down and in between
shows we're like all right let's get
this better and this better than this
better we kind of came out with this
like really amped up energy and I felt
like we got it all in the next show and
we're like oh it's gonna be all the
second show when we edit this thing
together it's gonna be mostly the second
show and nothing from the first show we
looked at and we're like nope first show
look at how natural we are right look at
how much like how real this there was a
weird pause there where I looked at you
or we did react to what the audience was
reacting as opposed to just being trying
to fix the things that we did wrong
right in the first show more robotic
second show so I love the realness of
the reaction and then what that made us
do and then waving you off and like in
the middle being like how come no one's
roasted Jeff finally because we know a
great roast comes from love and there
was a lot of love between the two of us
you know absolutely Jeff and for Jeff -
Jeff - I mean that's all I remember like
in 1994 going to New York and working at
Boston comedy club with Jeff Ross who
had hair at that time but he's doing
bits about like living with his grandpa
and his grandpa saggy balls and I mean I
can
remember all these classics he was
classic balls we had him on our show in
97 like Jeff has been a part of stuff
that we've done absolutely forever so to
be able to like give it to him felt
great he loved it he loved it and I and
again in that moment we were saying
almost saying thank you for pushing us
to do this because you guys didn't want
to it we did not want to originally you
and Jeff asked us and we initially said
I don't think so and then Jeff said just
you know do it but because just like in
my mind I see what this is gonna be he
could see because he has a wide view of
the whole thing and he was like this is
gonna be great because we've never done
this before and you guys can do this in
a way and I and we've never done it
before we built a whole career that's
been in a different direction now the
whole career was almost a setup for this
being upon 100% by the way I mean I we
could all see it and then every time you
guys from the belly room judging we
could see it too like oh my god these
guys going at each other
you guys go our eyes the the Rose battle
so what I loved is when a week before
we're judging in the belly room and
before it's over it's on periscope
everybody who's watching I love that you
did this because you were like there's
no turning back now
there's no turn you asked us since I
told Comedy Central you're like are you
guys gonna do it and load us on the spot
real moment we're like yep we're gonna
do it and and Jeff said something so
great he said something that Jon Stewart
said to him he passed that on to us
where he's like he's an Andrew he was
like Jeff dropped that one he said live
in the discomfort out of the discomfort
comes funny we were uncomfortable with
the notion of doing this because number
one we had never done it before yes we a
judge we've done roaster but like there
is a different we have a respect for it
it's almost like a when you
it's like Siegfried and Roy you know the
Tigers are there it's like you gotta
love them but you got you got to realize
that they could bite your neck
off right so you realize how difficult
it is and the better the bet combo we
had secret are we wrong there weren't as
good as funny guys good roaster and one
of them went for the other ones throat
but no but it is I was talking about
this last night yeah after you know
after the show I was like comedy is this
like illusion it's like a magic trick in
that the better you are at it the more
the regular people who don't do it think
they can do it because they you make it
look so easy right so we're smart enough
to know the see the strings and be like
it's not that easy you can't just assume
cuz we've judged that we're gonna be
good Roasters so we were taking it very
seriously
students of Comedy students guys are
awesome you know funny is really
underrated and it's really kind of
second a compliment I mean I think
you're funny everybody's favorite
nobody's hey which is like the nicest
thing and then every time I think about
that I'm like why is right it's so sad
so sad
[Applause]